former proud boys leader
sent sentenced to 22 years in prison a
Wall Street Journal story hello Wall
Street Journal story uh let's go through
this here former proud boys leader
Enrique is a 22-year sentence the
longest in over a thousand cases related
to January 6 20 21 Capital assault after
being convicted of
sadacious conspiracy a charge related to
efforts to use Force to overthrow the
government impede its law or seize its
property prosecutors initially sought a
33-year sentence for Taria but
Saturday's leadership role and the proud
boys involvement attack when
recommending to punishment or while the
U.S District Court Judge Timothy Kelly
Express discomfort likening the events
to terrorism tario who did not enter the
capital himself apologized for his role
in instigating the events while his
defense team argued for a 15-year
sentence saying my client is no
terrorist my client is misguided Patriot
wait he never went in he's getting 20
that's the key he never even went inside
there so it's getting further and
further from the supposed
insurrectionists the rioters the
terrorists he wasn't in there uh he's
he's not a white supremacist Joe Biden
is quick to call proud boys a white
supremacy group his name is Enrique
he's a he's an afro-hispanic gentleman
and he's going to lose his whole 40s
he's going to be in prison from 39 to 51
if he gets out early what do you think
the sentence should be uh well let's
look at this does he have a prior record
has he done anything wrong in the past
because um you know the whole thing with
Biden is we got to give people second
third and fourth chance if it's someone
on the left but if it's someone on the
right oh give him life he wasn't even
there so
[Music]
first of all I I did because I'm gonna
be honest I didn't dive in and find out
all because I mean the guy was at his
house I don't know he planned
orchestrated my question is do you guys
remember that that group Pat you guys
might have remembered
um antifa during the entire during the
entire Trump presidency during the
George Floyd riots these these people
who are peaceful protesters he's a
protested funded by George Patton they
caused absolute Mayhem in this country
they cause violence they killed people
they burn down cities they did all this
guess what when they got arrested
guess who bailed them out Hollywood
Elites uh Kamala Harris everybody's like
hey we got to help these people yeah
everybody yeah then they help them out
so however soon they got out that's how
quickly Enrique yeah exactly and guess
what on this January 6th this
Insurrection quotation marks that nobody
died nobody brought their guns nobody
nobody go to Liberty Safe to get their
guns exactly but here's is my thing
there I I think Adam I think a fair
thing would be you know if he did really
really incite violence like the ray Epps
the guy the the FBI that were like
everybody go in those people should be
in prison with these guys if that's
gonna be the case and if Trump wins I
genuinely hope that he takes all those
guys and partners so answer the question
then how long should he go to jail for I
I said a trick question
the specifics of what what evidence do
they have three months plus probation
okay because let me just you read the
article it's in front of your face yeah
they were they were trying number one I
don't really give a about this guy
we actually had the opportunity to bring
him on the podcast we said no
2021 yeah Pat's credit he's like nah you
know uh we don't go down that that far
right Rabbit Hole uh proud boy thing but
I will say this the prosecutor sought a
33-year sentence but what did his
defense want what did his defense ask
for a bargaining chip for how much how
many years 15 years 15 years so his
defense his defense attorney said at the
very least give him 15 years they
settled they split the difference in 22
years so I'm just looking at it was
defense is basically saying basically
his defense is basically saying you're
going to jail buddy for a while so this
whole thing by the way by the way good
point okay that even his defense is
saying 15 years not saying nothing but
also good point on you if he's got to go
absa's got to go absolutely they both go
on the same cell for 15 years now you're
going to say fair but oh Epps gets off
why he's saying get into gun get into
get into Capital get into capital and
there's videos EPS has got to be inmates
I agree roommates with this guy we can
sit there and say you're being
reasonable I will say this guy rayab
should be charged with something but
what he has not charged should not be
charged with is this seditious
conspiracy but this is my speculation I
haven't read into this all that much but
I know what a suggestions conspiracy is
he'd even go in the capital it's kind of
like he was a party promoter he promoted
the party yeah it's called he sent out
flyers he advertised the hell out of it
that's but he just didn't go to the
pattern that's called inciting a riot
that's called and that's called inciting
an Insurrection he's telling all these
young he's pushing the gates and pushing
them to go in he deserves I'm not
talking about ABS I'm talking about why
Enrique Atari was going to jail he was
the big party promoter of the of the and
I'm not even on your okay I'm on your
page yeah I don't think it was an
Insurrection I think it was a rebellion
yeah I think it was a show I'm not
on the Insurrection label I get that
people are calling you think I don't
think these proud boys were actually
going to take over the government I
agree I actually think a lot of them
actually do love America yeah have you
guys met any of The Proud boys have you
ever had a interaction with them I did a
comedy show in North Hollywood
California guys on a bunch of polo
shirts after the show you're funny I go
what's going on with the polos oh you
don't know where the proud boys I go
what do you guys do yeah well antifa's
been beating up old ladies and
Christians walking to the uh the Trump
rallies so we're showing up now and
we're kind of giving them uh the
business if they mess with us I said
that sounds almost Noble like kind of
like a counter force and uh they say you
want to join I said no thanks and by the
way
let's go hang out yeah I'd be with uh
but um they were all by the way black
guys so not even the white wait so wait
they're white supremacist black guys
that doesn't make sense I know it didn't
make sense
operate what Kayvon said my mom was not
on the camera but she was in oh she
was in Washington DC soccer alert right
yes yes she wasn't on the capitol but
the proud boys were providing security
to the older ladies my mom's in her 70s
they were guiding her around the city
like badass Boy Scouts and when a little
guy jumps out of the bushes with tight
black pants and throws an egg they would
just go put him in the hospital yeah
there's groups called the guardian
angels with red shirts that go back like
in the 80s yes yeah with all this and um
you know I look at it this way I'm not
in the courtroom here but if these if he
gets 22 years then the three people that
organized the Kavanaugh Riot and protest
don't they get two some you know do you
remember this the Justice Kavanaugh Riot
they did the same thing broke through
the doors came inside pushed the cops
around and then it's I'm looking at it
saying what is the difference here why
don't those people get two years for
inciting a riot and breaking through the
doors and trying to make this protest
and then these guys get 22 years yeah I
just
um I I'm still troubled by The Selective
prosecution here well I will say this
that one of the things you have to love
about America is your ability to protest
or even right 164 people arrested during
the protest for crowding obstructing or
and commodity they broke doors they came
in there they had looked tell me what
the difference is tell me what the
difference is when these guys broke
through the Kavanaugh they came around
tell me you know you know why because
they're registered Democrat that's why
and they're I'm saying okay 22 years why
don't these guys I don't even remember
this but are you saying that this is
comparable to generation they stopped
the hearing of no they came in I want to
see what he's talking about this is
comparable to January 6th this in a way
once it breaks free here I'm saying I
want to see it I'm saying well this guy
gets 22 why do these people not get two
it's a fair question so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]